Peggy
18 hello I'm Alex Samano creative
director on Assassin's Creed unity and
I'm really proud to be able to show you
guys a little bit of what we started
working on to expand on the franchise
after launch including this whole new
content we've been building for you guys
this latest and newest addition to the
Assassin's Creed series
enjoy developed by a dedic team at
Ubisoft M dead Kings follows Arno after
the events of Assassin's Creed unity and
takes place in s a rural City around
Paris this is really early Alpha footage
that team has put together now true to
history this site is the real place
where the Royal bloodline of France was
buried it was actually sacked during the
French
Revolution it is dark and very different
from the rest of the
game
now under the city there's a real
necropolis a Labyrinth of tunnels filled
with ancient puzzles and a brand new
enemy faction the
Raiders you have a brand new weapon too
the guillotine gun which shoots
explosive ammunition and you can use
also use it at close range to cut down
your enemies this is truly the darkest
story that we've ever told on the
franchise in addition to the campaign in
s the season pass will give you more in
Revolutionary Paris you'll get to exper
expence everything Paris has to offer
with three brand new missions you can
meet new historical figures solve Murder
Mysteries and help the people fight for
Freedom Now customization is key and
with 30 brand new items to collect in
the season pass whatever your play style
you can have the perfect
Loadout and that's not all I have one
more surprise to share with you
Assassin's Creed Chronicles China is a
brand new downloadable game available
for All Season Pass owners that we
always try to innovate and this idea
began as a simple sketch and eventually
evolved into its own
project you get to play shiau across
16th century China use martial arts
collect awesome gear as you walk across
stunning Landscapes you get to meet
historical figures all through this
exotic art style neverbe seen on the
Assassin's Creed
franchise
there's a lot new content still in the
works this season pass is the biggest
and most diverse Assassin's Creed
experience yet but for now we have to go
back to adding the final touches to
Assassin's Creed Unity before it ships
stay tuned for
more